-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Former President Trump's
attorney Joe Tacopina
said in a new interview
that it was a, quote,
"relief" to see the final
charges against Trump.
Alright, you know it's bad
when 34 felonies is a relief.
Phew, really dodged
a bullet there.
After attending a rally
in Manhattan
in support of former
President Trump on Tuesday,
Georgia Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
criticized New York
during an interview
with Fox News host
Tucker Carlson
and said, "I think
it's a very terrible place."
But the joke's on you,
Marjorie,
because once you think that,
you're officially a New Yorker.
[ Laughter ]
After he was arraigned
on Tuesday in Manhattan,
Former President Trump
reportedly
sat on the patio at Mar-a-Lago
and used his iPad to play music
over the club's speakers,
including "Macho Man"
by the Village People.
"Hey man, you can't play
that here anymore,"
said the governor
of Florida.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report
from the EPA,
there are more than
1 million lead pipes
still in use in Florida.
And there are actually
more than that in New Jersey,
but they don't want
to have to use them.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
Lamborghini this week
unveiled its first
plug-in hybrid supercar.
Now you can help save
the planet for your children
from all three
of your marriages.
[ Laughter ]
A government official
in Singapore
was recently sentenced
to two years in jail
after he allegedly
sold more than
600 stolen printer cartridges
online.
No word on what happened to the
trillions of dollars he made.
I'm from the generation
where we had to buy
our own printer cartridge.
They get you on the cyan?
Is that the one
they get you on, Baze?
Yeah.
According to a new survey,
an estimated
44 million American adults
are experiencing
significant loneliness,
which explains why they were
willing to take a survey.
"No, it's not.
It's not a bad time at all."
A person walking
on a beach in Florida
recently found a 30-pound
bale of marijuana,
and they admittedly
did the right thing
and reported the 25-pound
bale of marijuana.
According to a new study,
poor sleep can increase
the risk of a stroke.
But on the plus side,
you got to hear this joke.
[ Light laughter ]
Two former prison guards
in Oklahoma
were recently sentenced
to probation for allegedly
forcing inmates to listen to the
song "Baby Shark" as punishment.
And it's worse than you think,
because they played it twice.
That's right, two former
prison guards in Oklahoma
were recently sentenced
to probation for allegedly
forcing inmates to listen
to the song "Baby Shark."
Meanwhile, a local charity
in New York
remains unpunished.
And that was a monologue,
everybody.